en colombie la cuisine est une affaire
de couple
aujourd'hui ue les 10 et alexander tous
deux réfugiés originaires de la colombie
ont démontré leur savoir faire à leur
ville d'accueil
le couple qui est un jeune garçon s'est
lancé le défi de faire un plat colombier
avec des produits vendus au marché
il découvre ici des produits bons la
camerise qui a aujourd'hui mais il y à
leur a dit il ya l'aïe
ils connaissent la tête d'ail ne sont
pas habitués d'utiliser la fleur d'ail
l'odeur de cuisson à base de crevettes
nordiques attire les curieux qui fait
découvrir son offre
c'est une première expérience pour les
autres donc c'est super intéressant du
coup sûr tout le monde ensemble
ça donne une chance à des gens comme lui
qui sont arrivés ici avec l'artiste rami
pour s'intégrer et met en valeur des
leurs cultures aussi donc mouettes tout
seul accueil aux nouveaux arrivants le
fait que rimouski soit aussi une ville
d'accueil pour les réfugiés trousseau
extraordinaire
ça donne un plus à la ville aussi le
marché public permet aux nouveaux
arrivants de développer des liens avec
les producteurs locaux
daniel kabungu originaire de république
centrafricaine a accepté de travailler
pour une pâtisserie le samedi même si
elle a déjà un emploi dans une résidence
pour personnes âgées et qu'elle complète
des études à l'université du québec à
rimouski
oui j'aime bien ça parce que ça me
permet de rencontrer du monde 6 et puis
parler avec des gens échanger avec des
gens dont moi j'aime ça la cuisine est
rassembleuse et permet aux réfugiés de
retrouver leurs repères dans leur pays
d'accueil
on se rend compte que beaucoup de
rimouskois et rimouskoises ne savent pas
encore qu'ils sont là et la façon de le
faire par la cuisine c'est une façon
aussi d'enrichir notre différence
culturelle ici isabelle damphousse
radio-canada rimouski